FEMALE SPEAKER: It really means
a lot to us for you to
come in here for this next 45
minutes and be with us.
So I just wanted to start out
with asking Sarah, how did you
first hear about this story?
SARAH BURNS: Well, I was too
young in 1989 to have known
about this case.
And so I didn't learn about it
until 2003, when I was in
college, and I spent a summer
working for a civil rights
lawyer who was involved
in the civil suit
that's now ongoing still.
In 2003, it had not been filed
yet, and today it is
almost 10 years old.
But I learned about
the case then by
working with these lawyers.
And I actually met Raymond
and Kevin that summer.
And I was just so outraged by
the story, and so interested,
and it sort of fit with
what I was studying.
And so I ended up writing
my senior essay in
college about it.
And then a couple years later
decided that I wanted to know
more about it, and really
tell the story.
And so I wrote the book.
And pretty early on in that
process, then we decided--
documentary filmmaking is the
family business for me.
And so it was so obvious that we
had to make this film, that
this was such an important
story, and one that people
really didn't know.
People often think they know
something about it.
They've heard some of it.
But the fact that the
convictions were vacated in
this case, most people we talked
to didn't know that.
And so we felt it was really
important just to, if nothing
else, set the record straight
about what happened here.
But I think there are also
a lot of really important
lessons to be learned from
this story about false
confessions, about this sort of
rush to judgment that came
in the media, and really for
everyone that sort of bought
this story that the police
provided and
really believed it.
And so I think that trying to
understand those forces are
really important, not just for
understanding this case but
for thinking about how this
happens and why it happens and
how we can prevent it from
happening again.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Korey, what did
you think when Sarah came
to you and said that she wanted
to write the book?
KOREY WISE: Well, she had called
me, and when she had
called me, I was just so caught
up in my own little
world, I didn't remember our
conversation until she had
reminded me.
And I said, sure.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What
about you, Raymond?
What was your first reaction?
RAYMOND SANTANA: Well,
basically, because I had met
Sarah back in '03, and she had
done the paper, through
conversation and her knowledge
of all the facts in the case,
and then going into the book, we
had developed a friendship
by that time, and so the trust
was already there.
And we knew that the movie was
going to be told right,
because Sarah knew
all the facts.
She really did her research.
And we were really impressed
with this young lady that took
an interest and stood out.
And she was willing to put her
life kind of on hold to help
us out, and we were very
grateful for that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And we're going
to see a clip in just a
few minutes that shows a little
bit more about what
happened where the film left off
when all of you boys were
picked up-- boys at the time,
14 to 16 years old.
But Sarah, could you talk
a little bit more--
I mean, we set up the climate
in New York at the time, but
what was it like?
What explains that
this happened?
SARAH BURNS: Yeah.
What you've seen here is
basically just meeting the
characters in our story, these
five men and also the City of
New York, which is a really
important character.
And I think you see
here it's very
different than it is today.
I don't know how many of you
were living here in '89, but
it was a very different city.
And so I think part of
understanding the reaction to
the case is understanding what
was going on-- these sort of
incidents that had happened in
the decade leading up to it
that had sort of increased
racial tension and made people
very aware of this sort of
us-versus-them thing that was
happening in the city that this
case really fit into.
Basically, what happens--
I guess I'll kind of catch you
up just a little bit to the
clip that we're going
to see next.
This group of teenagers,
including our five, go into
the park this night
in April 1989.
And some of them are arrested
leaving the park because some
people in this larger group
had harassed, and in some
cases, assaulted some joggers
and bicyclists in the park.
And not everyone in
the group and--
but there were a few crimes
that were committed there.
And so some of these
kids are picked up.
And then a few hours later, the
police discover a woman
who had been jogging in the park
who was found near death,
who had been brutally
raped and beaten.
And it's a miracle that
she survived.
It was really a horrific
crime.
And so they jumped to the
conclusion that these kids who
had been in the park were
responsible for this crime,
and they began interrogating
them with that assumption,
certain that they were talking
to the guilty parties and
using every tactic they had
in their arsenal to get
confessions.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And we'll see
that clip in a moment.
But just to reiterate, so you
guys didn't know each other,
necessarily--
KOREY WISE: No.
FEMALE SPEAKER: --that night.
Did you, Raymond?
Had you kind of seen the
other four guys, or?
RAYMOND SANTANA: No.
I didn't know any of
them on that night.
So that's why when you look back
at the statements and how
the whole case unraveled, it's
pretty easy to see how that
can happen, especially when
you don't know them.
In Korey's instance,
he knew Yusef.
And so they were really
good friends.
And you'll see the clip-- well,
I don't know if you guys
will see the clip in the movie,
but if you get to see
the movie, it tells you how
the police stopped Yusef.
And they have his name on a
list, but Korey's name isn't
on the list.
And because their friendship
was so strong, the police
said, well, just come with
him, and you'll be back.
And he wound up coming
back 13 years later.
So--
FEMALE SPEAKER: There's these
four different confessions
that are totally mismatching.
How does it end up that
they end up in prison?
SARAH BURNS: Right.
Ultimately, this is just a
portion of what happens in the
interrogations.
Later, they pick up Korey and
Yusef and interrogate them.
And ultimately, four of the
five that we're getting to
know give these videotaped
statements, which end up being
this really powerful
piece of evidence.
They're these sort of
rehearsed things.
They've already given written
statements, the police have
sort of fed all of the
information, and they give
these statements, and
that's what gets
presented to the jury.
And it's very convincing.
It's hard for people to
understand why someone would
falsely confess.
And so it was really important
to us in the film to really
try to understand--
and these guys explained
it so well--
try to understand how
that could happen.
Because the jury looked at that
and believed it, even
though, as he has said, the
details were wrong.
Antron talks about describing
a different person than what
he was wearing.
That's not what the jogger
was wearing.
They get the location
of the attack--
everything is wrong.
And the amazing thing is that
people so wanted to believe
this story.
The police wanted
to believe it.
They wanted to have
the right guys.
And they shared this with the
media as if it were fact, and
people just bought it.
And so later on, they
start getting
forensic evidence back.
DNA tests are negative.
There's no blood anywhere
in this incredibly
bloody crime scene.
There's no blood anywhere
on any of these guys.
And they just plow ahead,
with really terrifying
consequences.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Raymond, during
the trial, you must
have been thinking, like,
there's no way that this is
going to happen, right?
RAYMOND SANTANA: Well,
basically, because we were
still young, it kind
of goes over your
head, the whole scene.
You're kind of numb to it.
And there was a part during
trial where the lawyers took
us in the back and they said,
you know, we're looking to get
a plea deal because we're
going to lose this case.
And so they wanted to negotiate
a plea deal, but it
had to be all three
of us, which is
me, Yusef, and Antron.
And we looked at each other,
and were like, no.
We're not taking a plea deal.
We didn't do it.
And I remember Yusef was--
and at that point, I had
over a year and a half
incarcerated.
And so I would have benefited
if I would have
taken a plea deal.
But I remember Yusef was really
gung-ho, and he stuck
to his guns and he
was like, no.
They can give me my life
and a day, and I'm
just going to do it.
But I'm not going to cop
out to something
that we didn't do.
And we were like, yeah,
you're right.
And we stuck to it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
And then you two, Korey and
Raymond, end up spending 7 to
13 years in prison.
KOREY WISE: Did the Rikers
Island thing--
RAYMOND SANTANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
KOREY WISE: --for about,
what, two years.
And it was mainly just
that, just going back
and forth to court.
Learning whatever I
could learn about
myself and the case.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
And you talk a lot in the film
about having to grow up, and
that's no way to grow up--
being boys in there
amongst other men.
KOREY WISE: No.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So if you, of
course-- and I want to make
sure we get a chance
to take questions--
but fast forward in the film,
and you heard the voice of
Matthias Reyes at the beginning
confessing to the crime.
Korey, you actually ended up
having two encounters with him
when you were in prison.
Could you tell us about that?
KOREY WISE: Oh, boy, boy, boy.
My boy, destiny.
That's what it was--
destiny.
"Good Day New York" would
have a great one.
Destiny.
When I was on the streets as
a kid, I watched a program
called "Video Music Box" with
Ralph McDaniels, who would do
hip hop and R&B. So I
was very into that.
That's the only thing that's
good for the neighborhood.
So I brought it with me to
Rikers Island, unexpectedly,
but I brought it with me, just
the mind state of "Video Music
Box."
I became a porter there.
I lived in a box in the Bronx.
The box is called
23 Hour Lock In.
So the officers, for my two
years I was there, when they
got to work, about 10 to 3:00,
they let me out of my cell.
So every time I came out of my
cell, I thanked them for doing
it, because they
didn't have to.
So I came out, cleaned
up, and [INAUDIBLE].
And it was also called
CMC housing--
Centrally Monitored Case.
And I had quite a few people
down there with me.
So I came out.
I went to the day room door,
opened it up, and they had
hollered at the bubble where
the officer was at, so they
could put the television on.
So they did that.
So I had turned on the channel
of "Video Music Box." But it
didn't come on yet.
It was about a good five minutes
before it came on.
So I did that, turned it up
a little bit, and get the
cleaning stuff ready to clean
up before dinner come in.
So as I'm doing my cleaning,
I'm hearing doors open up,
cells over my head open up.
So 3:00, they came in, and I'm
hearing "Video Music Box"
going on in the day room.
So the two end gates for the
north and south opens out,
because some of my CMC
colleagues was on the other
side on their way to my
side, to the day room.
So I didn't hear the
music no more.
I don't know whether I wasn't
paying attention to it or not,
but I didn't hear the music.
So I stopped what I was doing,
and I went on to the day room.
And when I got to the day room
door, my destiny was standing
in front of television.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And that
was Matthias Reyes--
KOREY WISE: Right.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Who
was another--
KOREY WISE: And I just told him,
I said, excuse me, can
you put it back on the channel
that was there?
He said, I'm not
watching that.
So I said, I was.
But you're doing something.
Don't worry about
what I'm doing.
Please put it back
and just relax.
And long story short,
we went to blows.
And so after we went
to blows, I guess--
but when I saw him about
a year or two ago--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
so then about, what?
10 years later--
SARAH BURNS: 13, yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: --you end up--
13 years later--
KOREY WISE: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: --you end
up seeing him again.
KOREY WISE: Well, I saw him,
and when I saw him, he was
playing stick ball.
So he was in--
and I guess, when he did
come see me, I guess
word got back to him.
I don't know.
But when he did see me, he
just said, hey, Wise.
I was on the basketball court
just waiting for those doors
to open up, because we
all just came out
of the program there.
It was about 5,000 of
us out in the yard.
And when he called me,
I looked at him.
He said, yo, Wise.
I said, hey, what's up?
So, you're Wise?
Yeah.
You got mail for me?
He said, no.
I'd like to apologize to you.
He had his own intentions.
But I said, apologize
to me for what?
No, because we had a fight
over the television.
Oh, don't worry about it.
We're here, don't
worry about it.
It's not going to do
nothing with me.
Don't worry about it.
No, you always maintain,
you know.
But I didn't know he was going
to be the destiny to this.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So shortly after that, he
ends up confessing.
SARAH BURNS: Soon after he
apologized to Korey about that
incident, he started asking
around and talking to people
in the prison and ultimately
confessed that he had raped
the Central Park Jogger and
that he had done it alone.
And that began an exhaustive
reinvestigation by the
district attorney's office
into his story.
And they tested his DNA, and it
matched the single sample
of DNA that had been present
at the crime scene from the
beginning that had, of course,
matched none of the five.
And it matched Reyes.
And they checked out his story,
and it fit the details
of the crime in a way that these
statements taken within
days had not.
And so ultimately, the district
attorney's office
joined in a motion to vacate
the convictions, which
happened in 2002.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Raymond,
what was it like when--
how did you find out that the
convictions had been vacated?
RAYMOND SANTANA: Well, was I was
serving a three and a half
to seven year sentence at
Franklin Correction Facility
for possession with the
intent to distribute.
And they brought me back down
to Downstate, which is
indoctrination into the
Department of Corrections.
And so it was there that
they brought me--
and I didn't know it was
officers at first.
And they were trying to conduct
an interview with me.
And their line, their reason was
that they wanted to change
juvenile laws.
So they looked at our case,
and they just wanted some
information.
But they kept asking about
Patricia Meili.
And so I kept asking why, and
they wouldn't tell me.
So we went on with
the meeting.
And then afterwards, I wind
up calling my dad.
And I said, you know, they
brought me back down here, and
they're asking about the case.
But, at that point, he
had known already.
The information got to him.
But I didn't know.
And so he says, well,
you know sit down.
I've got something
to tell you.
And I'm like, well what
you got to tell me?
And he's like, just sit down.
I'm like, well, what?
What is it?
We've got six minutes
on this phone.
SARAH BURNS: Right.
RAYMOND SANTANA: And he goes,
well, you know, they found the
guy that did your case.
And I'm like, what?
What are you talking about?
And he says, yeah.
They found the guy that
did your case.
You're going to be
coming home soon.
And I don't want to go into--
and so what happens is I
didn't believe him.
I was like, what?
Get out.
And I said, you know what?
I'll talk to you later.
And I really hung up on him.
FEMALE SPEAKER: He
hung up on him.
RAYMOND SANTANA: I
And I went back to my cell and
I thought about it, and I was
like, well, did they really
find this dude?
And it's been so long.
And I was really doubtful.
And I thought that they would
just try to make him the sixth
man and then just try to
sweep it under the rug.
And I was in denial all the way
until almost my release.
Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And not only had
Matthias Reyes raped other
women and beat them before the
night that you see in the
film, but having gone free, he
went on to do that in the
weeks after, too.
RAYMOND SANTANA: To add on to
what you just said, when he
went and confessed to the
district attorney's office
during the investigation,
they didn't believe him.
And so what he did was he went
on to solve, like, four
unsolved cases.
And then that's when they
took him serious.
SARAH BURNS: Right.
He had been arrested later in
1989 and eventually pled
guilty to a series of rapes,
including a rape-murder that
he committed, unrelated to
this case, that he had
committed through that
same summer.
And so he was serving a life
sentence starting at around
that same time.
But the fact that they had
overlooked this evidence that
was there, that existed even
in those days, that he was
responsible for the Central
Park Jogger rape not only
meant that these guys spent
many years in prison for
something they didn't do but
also that Reyes was left on
the street to commit these
other crimes that he was
eventually convicted of.
Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So I want to see
if anybody in the audience
wants to ask any questions, and
I'll probably just repeat
it so that it can be heard.
RAYMOND SANTANA: Don't all
raise your hand at once.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm just wondering
when was the first time that
attorneys became involved,
like during questioning?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
The question is, did you have
any attorneys during
questioning, like when you were
being interrogated when
they first picked you up?
KOREY WISE: No.
RAYMOND SANTANA: No.
Basically, at that point,
because we were so young, a
lot of that goes
over your head.
You don't know what Miranda
Rights are.
You don't know to say, hold
on, I need an attorney.
All you're saying is
where's my dad?
Where's my mom?
That's the first person
you're looking for.
And even when they come, the
police have a way of
maneuvering around that, which
you'll see in the film.
So if they want you that bad,
they're going to do everything
they have to.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
And you talked about in the
film, Sarah, the immense
pressure to make sure
that someone
was brought to justice.
SARAH BURNS: Sure.
I mean, I think the police knew
right away that this was
going to be a big story, that
it happened in Central Park,
and the sort of nature
of the crime.
I think there was an immediate
understanding that this was a
case that they were going to be
under a lot of pressure to
solve quickly.
And they were determined
to do that.
They had this idea, and they
went with it, and they used
all their tricks.
And the power dynamic in an
interrogation room between
seasoned homicide detectives
with 20 years of experience
and a 14-, 15-, or 16-year-old
is pretty extraordinary.
They were all read their Miranda
Rights, but people
don't understand what
that means.
And this is sort of before the
days of "Law & Order" even,
when everyone is kind of
familiar with these rituals.
You don't know what that means
when you're a kid, and you
don't have the support.
And the police are telling
you that you're
not really in trouble.
We just need to ask you
a few questions.
And they have these ways of
sort of glossing over this
stuff and keeping the parents
at bay and sort of keeping
everyone in the dark
about what their
intentions really are.
And the interesting thing is
that there were a large group
of kids who had gone to the park
that night, and most of
them, at some point over these
couple of days, were brought
in and interrogated.
And some of those kids had
records or had been in trouble
before, or some of them
had parents who--
someone's parents worked in
corrections and sort of knew a
little bit more about
this system.
And so those were the kids who
said, I want a lawyer, or I'm
not going to say anything.
And so ultimately, people
sometimes ask me, well, why
did the police target these five
out of all these kids?
They targeted everyone, and I
think that these guys were, in
some ways because of their
innocence, the most
vulnerable.
They were the ones who hadn't
been arrested, who hadn't been
in trouble, who didn't know how
to navigate the system.
And their parents and guardians,
to the extent that
they were there, didn't know
that either, didn't have
experience with that, and didn't
know what to do or how
to help them.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yep.
Other questions?
Yeah.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I'm curious--
given that you were so young
when you were arrested, you
weren't finished school
by that time.
Have you been able to
finish school since?
And also, when you were in
prison, was there any attempt
to give you the schooling that
you were missing by not being
on the outside?
RAYMOND SANTANA: Yeah.
I was going to the ninth
grade at that time.
And so I was in eighth grade.
And I wound up doing the rest of
the eighth grade in SPOFIT.
And then I remember my junior
high school graduated me to
high school.
And so I was in with
[INAUDIBLE].
My father was was receiving
cut cards
when I was in prison.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, jeez.
RAYMOND SANTANA: Yeah.
And so after I was convicted
and I reached Goshen Secure
Center, there was a program that
I was able to get my GED,
and I was able to go to college
and get an associate's
degree before Pataki
cut the program.
Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think we
have time for one more
question, then we'll
have to wrap it up.
AUDIENCE: What about
you, [INAUDIBLE]?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, excuse me.
Korey?
SARAH BURNS: You got
a GED, right?
Yeah.
KOREY WISE: Right before I got
kidnapped, I got it in
Stevenson High School
in the Bronx.
And then later on, as I went
through, they were still
trying to make me do the whole
high school thing again
because they had--
well, when you transition
like that, you have
to start brand new.
So shortly after that, I found
myself trying to do the
college before the Pataki
took it out.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
And they ended up stopping
the education program.
RAYMOND SANTANA: Right.
SARAH BURNS: They cut funding
for the program
that made that possible.
FEMALE SPEAKER: One
more question.
AUDIENCE: What do you want the
audience to take away from the
film, and what's been
the reaction?
SARAH BURNS: Well, we actually
just had a really amazing
screening last night as part of
the DOC NYC Film Festival,
where we had all five of the
Central Park Five together on
stage, and together in the same
place for the first time
since they were arraigned in
1989, which was a pretty
amazing experience.
I know it was for me.
I think it was for the
audience, too.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
SARAH BURNS: And we've really
been having a great experience
showing it to some audiences
and having--
I mean, you guys can talk about
a little bit of what
that feels like for you,
to get that kind of
response that you have.
But as far as what I
would hope people
take away from it--
as I said before, part
of this is about
just informing people.
This is what happened.
But we always made this film
not as a whodunit.
This wasn't a question.
We learned about this
case knowing that
these guys were innocent.
But as a how did this happen.
And so I think understanding
the ways that this happened
and the sort of mechanisms by
which a miscarriage of justice
like this happens is a really
important first step, and
hopefully the beginning of a
conversation about how do we
fix those things and how
do we prevent this
from happening again?
Because I think that despite the
fact that New York is very
different now than it was then,
I think that not enough
has changed, and certainly
something like this, I
believe, could happen again.
The interrogation tactics
are exactly the same.
And there's still, to this day,
no sense among the NYPD
that they even did anything
wrong or even that they got
this wrong.
They've resisted even the idea
that the convictions should
have been vacated.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
RAYMOND SANTANA: Yeah.
SARAH BURNS: So I say we still
need to be talking about this.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Korey and
Raymond, what has it been like
having to relive and
retell this story?
KOREY WISE: [INAUDIBLE]
to my destiny, it's really
still beyond me.
I'm still walking on
clouds right now.
Because [? real ?] talk.
I have no animosity towards my
brothers, but there was far
from a [? model ?]
on Rikers Island.
I just responded.
And as of now, I'm glad that
I'm alive, as well as my
brother, Raymond, and the
rest of the guys,
Kevin, Yusef, McCray.
I'm glad we're all
alive to tell our
own individual stories.
And so the world, who's been
hearing so much of the nasty
of it, they can finally see and
they can put this to rest.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Raymond?
RAYMOND SANTANA: For me,
basically, back in 1989, we
were 14-, 15-, and 16-year-olds
when this story happened.
And we were taken away-- our
voices were gone, also,
through the whole process.
So you never got to hear
Raymond, Korey, and the rest
of the guys' stories.
All you got to read was what
the media put together, the
interviews that they conducted
in our neighborhoods, and how
they dissected our lives, but
you never got to hear us.
And then we were also replaced
with Wild Thing, Urban
Terrorists, rapists,
Wolf Pack.
And so that became what was
associated with us.
The Central Park Five label was
something really negative.
And so what this movie does for
us is restore us and gives
us back our voices.
And what you guys do for us is
when you watch this movie and
you respond and you engage in
conversation with us and you
talk about how you feel and how
it makes you outraged, and
that's part of the healing
process for us--
to see the response that we get
from you guys now, because
in '89, there was nothing
but negative responses.
And now, in 2012, it's
nothing but positive.
And so it helps us
a great deal.
And what we want you guys to
take away from the movie is
also that we're not animals,
that we are human beings and
we were kids.
And we want you to indulge in
discussions with other people,
like Sarah said, and
find ways of how we
can put this to rest.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Go ahead, Korey.
KOREY WISE: As a hip hop fan,
the world Wild Thing that I'm
hearing so much about, it came
from a hip hop artist by the
name of Tone Loc.
He's more West Coast.
He had an old song called "Wild
Thing." and it went from
there to commercials, and it
started talking about food.
But when I was in Central
Bookings, I was hearing--
I don't know where I was hearing
it from, but I was
hearing "Wild Thing."
I was hearing it.
So when I was hearing it later
on, it was picked up and made
a negative out it.
It was positive, made a
negative out of it.
But it was picked up.
The media, they made
a negative--
that was out there,
[? "Wild Thing." ?]
So that's about it.
RAYMOND SANTANA: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And I know that
there's nothing that can
give back what you
were taken away.
But if people do want to help,
there is an ongoing case.
It's now been nine years--
a civil suit against the city.
And I know that you guys can't
talk about it too much, but
the hearing is upcoming
on December 17.
And if you are moved by this,
you can write letters to Mayor
Bloomberg and others to let them
know that we all know the
truth about what happened.
RAYMOND SANTANA: Yeah.
It's all about the numbers
at the end of the day.
That's what they respect--
how do people come out, how you
support, how you react,
what's your feedback.
We have a Facebook page, The
Central Park Five, that is
growing daily.
We're always on Facebook
and Twitter trying to
put the word out.
So we encourage you guys to come
on out and stand with us.
KOREY WISE: Every month that I
find myself in this federal
building without my coworkers
with me--
codefendants with me--
this city loves it.
They love not seeing no
media or supporters.
They love it.
RAYMOND SANTANA: Yeah.
KOREY WISE: They love it.
They love it.
And recently, when people have
been coming out, the city's
been getting nervous.
Trust me.
And for the first time, when I
saw the judge, when he came
out from his chambers to the
courtroom and he saw, he had
to take a double take.
He damn near caught a
heart attack that he
didn't expect that.
He said, what--
did I miss something here?
What's happening?
FEMALE SPEAKER: I bet.
RAYMOND SANTANA: Yeah.
KOREY WISE: So it helps.
And like I said, with
it, I pray.
As a spiritual person, I pray
that within my soul for
something like that to come
about because it was just
eating me up alive
for so long.
Coming up in there, there's no
rhythm going on up there.
They're just dragging.
The city's just dragging,
talking about nothing.
They're just dragging.
Nothing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Well, thank you for telling your
story, and the film, and
the book, and being here.
I'm sure it's really difficult,
but we really
appreciate it.
And thank you, Sarah.
And she made the film with
her husband Dave
and her father Ken.
Thanks to you all for making
the story happen.
SARAH BURNS: Thank you.